Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In this series, we talk quite a bit about
neural network-based learning methods that
are able to generate new images for us from
some sort of sparse description, like a written
sentence, or a set of controllable parameters.
These can enable us mere mortals without artistic
skills to come up with novel images.
However, one thing that comes up with almost
every single one of these techniques is the
lack of artistic control.
You see, if we provide a very coarse input,
there are many-many different ways for the
neural networks to create photorealistic images
from them.
So, how do we get more control over these
results?
An earlier paper from NVIDIA generated human
faces for us and used a latent space technique
that allows us some more fine-grained control
over the images.
It is beyond amazing.
But, these are called latent variables because
they represent the inner thinking process
of the neural network, and they do not exactly
map to our intuition of facial features in
reality.
And now, have a look at this new technique
that allows us to edit the geometry of the
jawline of a person, put a smile on someone’s
face in a more peaceful way than seen in some
Batman movies, or, remove the sunglasses and
add some crazy hair at the same time.
Even changing the hair of someone while adding
an earring with a prescribed shape is also
possible.
Whoa!
And I just keep talking and talking about
artistic control, so it’s great that these
shapes are supported, but what about an other
important aspect of artistic control, for
instance, colors?
Yup, that is also supported.
Here you see that the color of the woman’s
eyes can be changed, and, the technique also
understands the concept of makeup as well.
How cool is that!
Not only that, but it is also blazing fast.
It takes roughly 50 milliseconds to create
these images with the resolution of 512 by
512, so in short, we can do this about 20
times per second.
Make sure to have a look at the paper that
also contains a validation section against
other techniques and reference results, turns
out there is such a thing as a reference result
in this case, which is really cool, and you
will also find a novel style loss formulation
that makes all this crazy wizardry happen.
No web app for this one, however, the source
code is also available free of charge and
under a permissive license, so let the experiments
begin!
If you have enjoyed this video and you feel
that a bunch of these videos are worth 3 dollars
a month, please consider supporting us on
Patreon.
In return, we can offer you early access to
these episodes, and more, to keep your paper
addiction in check.
It truly is a privilege for me to be able
to keep making these videos, I am really enjoying
the journey, and this is only possible because
of your support on Patreon.
This is why every episode ends with, you guessed
it right…
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!